mexico ici embouteilleurs et marchands
de produits sucrés s'arrache l'espace
public même au zocalo les décorations de
noël sont aux couleurs de coca cola mais
au fil des ans
le mexique est devenu un laboratoire
vivant sur les conséquences néfastes du
sucre sur la santé ceps 70% des adultes
de mexicains ont un surpoids ou sont
obèses et maintenant le système de santé
est en train de s'effondrer au mexique
et au canada
l'industrie du sucre aura également les
grands moyens pour séduire les
consommateurs
ici un canadien sur quatre est obèse
qu'un lieu de se questionner pourquoi
santé canada n'intervient pas de façon
plus musclée sur le succès compte tenu
qu'on saigne dommage que ça fait
la bataille du sucre une guerre à finir
entre les gouvernements et l'industrie
le lab est ce que c'est un lob et
quittait qui très très très puissant on
parle de 2 milliards de dollars
sur 20000 aliments disponibles dans les
épiceries 16000 contiennent du sucre
ajouté le problème avec le succès
maintenant qui se retrouve dans
pratiquement tous nos aliments
transformés à l'épicerie même les
allemands qu'on soupçonne de moins comme
le pain et les céréales le you go
même les sauces à spaghetti qui se
disent santé le dh sur les sucres
ajoutés sont problématiques
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
fondation canadienne des maladies du
coeur
diverses organisations médicales dix
c'est un domaine mûr pour une cure
d'amaigrissement derksen pour
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'idéal est de ne pas dépasser 6
cuillères à thé par jour pour une femme
et 9 pour un homme mais en réalité du
sucre on en consomme trop beaucoup trop
en une seule journée on consomme
facilement trois fois plus de sucre
ajouté que ce qui est recommandé ce que
critiquent depuis des années yoni
freedhoff médecins et spécialistes en
obésité deux ans des études suggèrent
que le sucre pu jouer un rôle dans
l'apparition du diabète de maladies
cardiovasculaires de maladies du foie
et pour cause le secret fine et s'est
immiscé dans notre alimentation
aux etats unis la consommation annuelle
moyenne d'environ 2 kg au début du 19e
siècle atteint aujourd'hui plus de 40 kg
par habitant et nous car on grossit au
même rythme que notre consommation de
sucre
la quantité de sucre ajouté qu'on a
malheureusement développer dans notre
consommation à dépasser une limite que
le corps n'est plus capable de compenser
par d'autres mécanismes naturels
d'où l'apparition de tous ses effets
néfastes sur la santé
sans compter le coût astronomique en
soins de santé associés à l'obésité 7
milliards de dollars par année au canada
seulement
julie st-pierre et pédiatres et experts
conseillent à l'américaine est associée
chez tous les jours dans sa clinique
elle constate les ravages causés par le
sucre nous épidémiologistes soutiennent
de façon très sérieuse que les plusieurs
de ces malades il a associé à l'obésité
vont créer non seulement les
conséquences économiques importantes en
termes de soins de santé mais vont
malheureusement contribué au déclin de
l'espérance de vie chez nos jeunes si la
tendance se maintient nos enfants pour
avoir une espérance de vie plus courte
que la nôtre au canada les jeunes de 9 à
18 ans consomment en moyenne un demi
litre de boissons sucrées par jour
corinne voyez coalition québécoise sur
la problématique du poids on sait que la
seule consommation quotidienne d'une
boisson ce prix va augmenter de 60% le
risque pour un enfant de devenir obèses
le supplique et dans un effet très
néfastes sur la santé bien documenté ça
rend tellement vite dans l'organisme que
c'est le foie qui métabolise ce club et
ça crée un foie gras et d'autres organes
grands
184 mille c'est le nombre de décès
attribuables chaque année à la
consommation excessive de boissons
sucrées dans le monde
et c'est ici au mexique qu'on en compte
le plus vingt-quatre mille décès par un
lieu bien malgré lui
le mexique est devenu un laboratoire
vivant sur les conséquences néfastes du
sucre sur la santé
c'est très clair quand on observe la
croissance de la consommation des
boissons sucrées
on constate aussi la croissance des cas
d'obésité de diabète et autres problèmes
il n'y a donc aucun doute les boissons
sucrées sont un des plus importants
facteurs dans le problème de l'obésité
et du diabète au mexique
du comptoir à tacos au restaurant cinq
étoiles les boissons sucrées sont sur
toutes les tables sont nous avons une
grande affection pour le coca cola mais
surtout froid
li mexico au mexique la consommation de
boissons sucrées commence à un très
jeune âge statistics date les
statistiques montrent par exemple qu'à
l'âge de trois mois environ 50 % des
bébés ont déjà consommé des boissons
sucrées rubrique résultats
le mexique a le plus haut taux d'obésité
infantile au monde
31% et la situation n'est guère plus
reluisante ici en 2016 au canada une
personne sur quatre est obèse
et comme au mexique le sucre en serait
en partie responsable
80 pour sa part this man 2 des produits
que l'on achète actuellement contient du
sucre alors c'est certain que
actuellement l'enjeu est énorme pour le
secteur
le secteur de l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui tirent avantage de
notre dépendance au sucre
c'est comme un hacker 6-1 ajoute le
sucre mais le jeu vouloir jeter plus de
secours que le goût soit plus attrayant
pour développer une barre de marché
christopher findley tête des aliments
pour l'industrie depuis plus de 30 ans
seul de tous les ingrédients qu'on
ajoute aux aliments transformés ce cross
le sucre est de loin le plus simple à
utiliser
le sporting gijon disponible sous plus
de soixante noms différents
le sucre est un ingrédient clé
du développement des aliments d'un point
de vue économique
le sucre est un ingrédient relativement
bon marché qui meurent pratiquement pas
d'impact négatif sur l'appréciation d'un
aliment projet juno faut ajouter du
sucre devient donc un choix facile pour
un développeur de produits dans les
laboratoires de comme q-cells des
consommateurs sont payés pour goûter
l'objectif trouver la combinaison
d'ingrédients qui permet d'atteindre ce
que l'industrie appelle le point
d'extase le bleis paint ball le point
d'extase est au niveau idéal
d'ingrédients qui maximise le plaisir du
consommateur est ainsi en lui une
réaction positive en france russes
pensent et le sucre avouons le est le
plaisir coupable de la majorité d'entre
nous
le goût du sucre est programmée il ne
laisse place à aucune ambiguïté mais tu
es quelque chose de sucré sur la langue
d'un bd il sourit mettez-y quelque chose
d'amer il grimace nous sommes programmés
pour répondre positivement aux sucres et
que ce soit pour rendre une sauce plus
onctueuse ou un craquelin plus croquant
le sucre est encore l'ingrédient de
choix très difficile de trouver un
produit qui ne contiennent pas de sucre
parce que même en quantité un père serti
blues le sucre à d'autres fonctions il
ajoute du corps aux aliments consommés
en prenant de plus en plus de place dans
l'industrie de la transformation des
aliments
le sucre est devenu un ingrédient qui
vaut son pesant d'or vous savez le lab
est ce que c'est un lob et quittait
quitterait plus un mais lorsqu'on parle
d'ingrédients en amont on parle de
milliards de dollars et ses milliards ne
profite pas seulement à l'industrie mais
à nous tous l'or blanc fait fructifier
notre bas de laine
la caisse de dépôt et placement du
québec ld tier 3 milliards 385 millions
de dollars en actions dans douze
entreprises dont la rentabilité est
grandement attribuable à la vente de
produits sucrés
notre dépendance au sucre nous rapporte
gros même si elle nous rend malades
combattre l'épidémie d'obésité au
mexique est un défi de taille vélos en
libre-service gymnase en plein air la
ville de mexico adopte un certain nombre
d'initiatives pour contrer l'épidémie
d'obésité
cet appareil pour stimuler l'activité
physique récompenses sont l'utilisateur
d'un podomètre gracieuseté de la boisson
sucrée pareil
le puissant embouteilleurs n'est jamais
loin des près le premier président à
venir de l'opposition étaient vicente
fox
mais avant vicente fox était président
de coke au mexique alejandro calvillo
una défenseurs des droits des
consommateurs
nous savons que 70% des sucres ajoutés
est consommée par les mexicains viennent
de boissons sucrées km clm ceux-là
viennent de boissons contenant du sucre
ajouté que la première chose à faire est
donc de faire baisser la consommation de
ce type de boissons en janvier 2014 le
gouvernement mexicain adopte une mesures
agressives sous forme de taxes
nationales 10% sur les boissons sucrées
et 8% sur la malbouffe comme les
croustilles les biscuits les bonbons et
la crème blesse soldats taxer la taxe
est très importante parce qu'elle est le
seul moyen de commencer à changer des
comportements ancré dans la population
et comme en plus ce type de boissons
très sucrées créer un certain niveau de
dépendance
il faut suffisamment augmenté son prix
pour que l'alternative santé coûte moins
cher que le produit qui est mauvais pour
la santé
oui david dorman inférieur
l'impact est immédiate les ventes de
boissons sucrées baisse de 12% en 1 17 %
chez les classes défavorisées
à la même époque aux états unis des
tentatives de taxer les boissons sucrées
ichou le maire de new york michael
bloomberg
homme d'affaires riche et respecté perd
la face devant l'industrie
il veut interdire les gros format de
boissons gazeuses dans sa ville chérie
mais contesté par un front commun des
commerces visés la réglementation est
invalidée par la cour de l'état de new
york deux jours avant son entrée en
vigueur
plus d'une trentaine de municipalités
américaines ont tenté de taxer les
boissons gazeuses
la plupart des initiatives ont été
contestés avec succès devant les
tribunaux pourquoi démoniser un produit
qui pré avec modération comme l'ensemble
des produits et pas du tout le cfa la
santé donc c'est dans ce sens là que les
compagnies se défendre on n'acceptera
pas de voir nos produits ciblés par une
taxe injustifiée qui plient à notre sens
inefficace on pense vraiment pas que de
pénaliser les les citoyens en rajoutant
une taxe avoir un impact significatif 60
ont plus de s'introduire dans nos
aliments
le lobby du sucre prend les grands
moyens pour infiltrer des organisations
influentes auprès de l'opinion publique
l'industrie est contre la taxe et
cherche à se donner une bonne image en
faisant la promotion de l'activité
physique
coca cola est entre autres le principal
commanditaire de participaction on se
retrouve dans un conflit éthique ou ces
organismes ont à coeur la santé de la
population et le prince un des
principaux bailleurs de fonds vont
provenir de l'industrie agroalimentaire
qui est un contributeur à la
problématique qui veulent régler
l'obésité vous savez je m'inquiète de
ses engagements avec l'industrie
lorsqu'ils font perdre le sens critique
aux différents acteurs et ses acteurs
sont impliqués dans le domaine de la
santé publique
il me semble que participaction pour
répondre aux positions contre les
boissons pour sportifs mais ils ne le
font pas commanditer des événements
sportifs comme les jeux olympiques ou
financer des athlètes professionnels est
une autre stratégie de l'industrie qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité
on ya créé un lien affectif avec ce
produit là parce que quand car désolé
pète c'est spectaculaire
il ya des émotions qui se font ressentir
pillon ce sont tous des héros donc le
produit se positionne avec sept athlètes
là qu'il endosse il existe une seule
organisation avec laquelle il ne faut
pas s'associer
c'est bien celle du sucre et de
l'industrie des boissons sucrées
leur but est d'avoir le rôle du bon gars
martin pierre pelletier n'est pas de cet
avis
le choix des des compagnons de boisson
de s'investir dans des initiatives qui
visent à encourager le sport c'est
louable
ici dans ce sens là que s'inscrivent
aussi la leur effort
avec les comptes sociaux et
communautaires en flirtant aussi avec
les milieux académiques et scientifiques
l'industrie exel aller chez son image
l'institut canadien du sucre qui
représente en fait les sucriers canadien
huit pattes et l'antique en est un bon
exemple le sucre fait certainement
partie d'une saine alimentation et le
sucre est naturelle on le retrouve dans
les fruits les légumes les produits
laitiers est aussi dont la betterave à
sucre et la canne à sucre
d'où proviennent notre sucre de table
sur leur site internet
on retrouve un jeu questionnaire et même
une vidéo destinée aux jeunes qui
affirme que le sucre est naturelle et
donc inoffensif wakfu notre rôle c'est
d'éduquer communiquer de l'information
qui repose sur une base scientifique
pour influencer les diététistes
l'institut du sucre leur envoie
régulièrement des publications qui
blanchissent la réputation du sucre la
nutritionniste ne s'informent pas de la
source officielle ça paraît un document
crédible
donc si c'est de la publicité
scientifique qui envoyer directement à
un public celles qui sont les
nutritionnistes pour probablement
espérer voir ces effets le solitaire des
fondations comme le european jewish
institute et le globo angie balanced
network sont des façades en apparence
légitime qui emploient des
professionnels de la santé pour se
donner de la crédibilité
les médias ne s'intéressent vice
président du global energy balance
network le docteur stephen blais est
professeur à l'université de caroline du
sud
ces travaux ont entre autres contribué à
définir la politique américaine en
matière d'activité physique
quand on voit des nutritionnistes des
médecins s'associer à l'industrie pour
participer un délit c'est ou des
conseils de certains instituts
on vient donner une crédibilité à
l'organisme avec ces professionnels mais
nous on observe que c'est un conflit
d'intérêt majeur qui doit être déclaré
c'est ce qui est arrivé en novembre
dernier lorsqu on a appris que le club
orange hippolyte network était
commandité en grande partie par coca
cola à l'automne 2015 coca cola est
finalement contraint de faire la lumière
sur les liens financiers qui la lie à
d'innombrables études scientifiques et à
des professionnels de la santé en
publiant une liste de tous les
bénéficiaires de son financement
à défaut de nous accorder une entrevue
coca cola canada nous envoie une
déclaration the coca cola company
soutient depuis longtemps la recherche
scientifique
il est important pour nous que les
chercheurs avec lesquels nous
travaillons partagent leur propre point
de vue et résultats scientifiques
quel qu'il soit et qu'il fasse preuve de
transparence quant au financement que
nous leur avons fourni six au canada
c'est du bout des lèvres que le nouveau
gouvernement de justin trudeau se dit
intéressée à taxer les boissons sucrées
au mexique pourtant les résultats sont
si encourageants qu'on parle même de
l'augmenter de 10 à 20 pour ça l'ouïe
fine tap ni personne
nous croyons que 20% serait un bien
meilleur niveau pour réduire la
consommation et ainsi faire une réelle
différence
on n'a encore rien fait tout ça au
canada
on n'a fait aucun de ces changements
législatifs favorable et ce qu'on voit
c'est que le fardeau de la maladie
continue de croître et ce n'est pas
l'avis de changer pourquoi ça changerait
et le temps presse
d'ici 2020 un canadien sur trois sera
obèse taille aussi longtemps qu'on va
laisser l'industrie décidé elle de ce
qui amène ses produits on va avant
n'importe quoi sur le marché un jour où
gouvernement va décider de mettre en
place des mesures précises pour dire il
ya des quantités de sucre maximale
recommandée par exemple un mètre dans
les biscuits
l'industrie doit s'adapter puis va nous
offrir des produits qui sont plus
simples qui vont répondre à nos besoins